[Music]
bjorn lomberg is a danish author and
president of the copenhagen consensus
center a project-based u.s think tank
where prominent economists are seeking
to establish priorities for advancing
global welfare he's the former director
of the danish government's environmental
assessment institute in copenhagen
bjorn became known internationally for
his book the skeptical environmentalist
in 2001 and how to spend 75 billion
dollars to make the world a better place
cool it in 2007 which is also a movie
and lately published in 2018
prioritizing development a cost-benefit
analysis of the un's sustainable
development goals among many other works
and books
and so i'm hoping we'll have a very
productive conversation today and
welcome to this
discussion
thanks a lot jeremy all right so why
don't you just start by letting people
know what you've been up to
over the last let's say two decades i
know that's a very broad question and
and why i mean i've been interested in
talking to you because i read a number
of your books a few years ago and i was
interested in your economic analysis and
and as a way of determining which
which
crises let's say or which potential
crises are real and also how they might
be managed most intelligently
thanks a lot jordan so you know
fundamentally what i try to do is to say
and this really is very very obvious
we only have a limited amount of
resources so let's make sure we focus
those resources on the places where we
can help the most where we can do the
most good remember what is it that we
mostly focus on in the world it's very
often the things that get the headlines
the things that people talk about talk
about and very often that ends up being
the things that have you know the cutest
animals or the most crying babies of the
groups with the best pr and surely
that's not the right way to prioritize
the right way should be to look at if i
spend a dollar or a peso or a rupee here
will i do more good than if i spent that
same dollar of rupiah pizza over here so
basically asking across all the
different areas you can spend resources
where do i help the most now obviously
that's a huge conversation in and of
itself because it's not easy to just
determine that but the basic idea is
simply to say let's focus on the places
where you can do the most good rather
than the places where it makes us feel
the best about ourselves so that's
really what i've been trying to do for
for for two decades and you know
prioritizing the world and trying to say
where should you spend money of course
makes the the projects that we say these
are the really really great
interventions they all love us and think
we're like the best things that sliced
bread but of course the the projects and
the policies that are not so effective
they think we're terrible so yeah it
creates a lot of antagonism and makes a
lot of people annoyed and interested but
i think it's crucial to ask these
questions well one question would be
what's the alternative you know like
when i was looking at the un development
goals for example if i remember
correctly there was something
approximating 200 of them and this was a
few years ago i worked on a un panel and
i thought well the problem with 200
goals is that you can't have 200 they're
not goals if there's 200 of them because
you absolutely have to prioritize in
order to move forward assuming some
limitation on resources which is exactly
what what you what you just described
and so then then the question would
become
well how do you calculate benefit and
that's a really difficult problem which
is i think why it wasn't addressed with
the mishmash of 200 goals apart from the
fact that you're going to offend people
by rank ordering their priorities
so why don't you tell people a little
bit about the about the methods that you
used because i think they're extremely
interesting
so you're absolutely right the the
sustainable development goals we
actually work with the un back in 2015
when they were doing this i uh it was it
was it was about uh 60 to 90. it was
very unclear uh un ambassadors i
actually met with a quarter of them uh
in new york and talked to each one of
them said shouldn't we try to you know
focus on the targets that would do the
very most good and of course each one of
them
said yes individually but the
the the combined effort of all the u.n
ambassadors was of course not to
actually do the best goals it was to get
everybody's goals in there so you know
the norwegians had three ideas and the
brazilians had four and everybody else
had you know three or four that they
wanted in there that's why we ended up
with 169 targets uh which of course
simply means she promised everything to
everyone everywhere and that means a lot
of people are going to be very
disappointed when 2030 rolls around and
we haven't actually dealt with all the
things that we promised right so what
happens there what happens there is that
you
the people who are doing that and
including everyone on the list
maximize short-term emotional well-being
of the people who had been doing the
consultation at the cost of medium to
long-term progress but then again
they're not going to be around in 2030
in all possibility to suffer the
consequences of that so or or at least
yeah or at least they're not nobody's
gonna see that we failed to do as much
good as we possibly could because we
will have done a little bit of good
everywhere but doing a little good
everywhere is not nearly as good as
doing an enormous amount of good in the
places where you can do the very most
good with extra resources again remember
we're estimating the total cost of the
sdgs is somewhere in the in the range of
two and a half trillion dollars and the
actual amounts available is about 140
billion dollars so we literally have
five percent of what we're promising so
we're promising the world and then we
say hey here's a small amount of money
and let's spread it thinly so everybody
gets a little bit of it okay so that's
that's so that's partly where you derive
your premise that we're dealing with
limited resources is that you're
actually using a real number and the
number you're using is what's actually
available and when you wrote how to
spend 75 billion you basically took half
of what it was available
now yes that was about much much earlier
on and that was mostly sort of a
it's a fun idea to say how would you
spend a specific amount yes and that was
half uh so so we weren't saying we
should spend all of it in the exact way
that we were talking about
okay
so to agree with you people have to
agree that everything can't be done for
everyone all at once at infinite expense
and that it's useful practically and and
also
even in a utopian sense in a desirable
sense to rank order so that the obvious
money that's available the money that's
genuinely available can be targeted best
and so then the next question would be
how do you go about that in the least
controversial and most empirically sound
manner to do the rank ordering
so we use cost benefit analysis which is
a very well established economic tool
that tries to say all right for each of
the proposals that you come up with
how much will that proposal cost now
remember this is not just economics most
of the cost will be money but for
instance if you want to immunize uh
small children you also have to ask the
mothers to spend perhaps a day to go to
the place where their kids will be
immunized that'll both cost them labor
they can't do labor that day maybe
they'll have transportation costs
they'll have food costs there'll be
extra other costs so we try to add all
of those costs up and say so what's the
total cost of this project then we look
at all the benefits and remember the
benefits of both economic yes but
they're also social for instance kids
not dying or kids not being sick and
they are often also environmental so we
try to take all of those
all of those benefits so both the
economic the environmental and social
benefits add them all up into one number
that is denominated in dollars or rupees
or whatever your currency is and then
you can say well for this many dollars
you can do this much good and that means
you can also say for every dollar spent
you can do this much good now obviously
i'm simplifying this yeah but in a sense
what it means is if you do it right and
a lot of economists spend a lot of time
trying to make this right if you have
all the same parameters across all these
different areas it actually means you
can start comparing different
interventions across all the different
areas and say where do you get the
biggest bang for your buck and of course
that is what it matters if you're
actually going to do good so we did and
this is not please don't buy this book
because this is this is a very long and
academic book but we did this long and
academic book with with more than 50 of
the world's top economists looking
across all these different areas but the
beauty is you can actually put it in
just one chart and i'm going to show you
that and we'll also put it up here on
your website so this is the ones one
page chart
that has all the targets here
and for each of the targets there's an
analysis that says how much will this
cost how much good will it do and then
it shows for every dollar spent how much
good will it do if it's a long line
it'll do a lot of dollars of good if
it's a short line not so much so it
really becomes this very simple menu for
the world to say where can you spend
your resources and of course this
doesn't mean you know just like when you
go into a restaurant you get a menu
doesn't mean you buy the cheapest thing
or the most nutritious thing maybe
you're in the mood for you know
an unhealthy cake but it's incredibly
important to know what is the cost and
what's the benefit and knowing this
makes it a lot more likely that the
world is going to focus itself on some
of the really long bars where it can do
a lot of good for every dollar or group
your peso spent okay so now
if i was thinking about critiquing this
let's say from a social science enough
or or a
political perspective the first thing
that i would object is well how do you
how how is it that you know that your
calculation of the costs and the
benefits are accurate so
you and and how do you know that they're
essentially as free as possible of any
undue political bias
so because your critics no doubt will
object as perhaps they should that there
will be
let's call them implicit biases even
though i'm not a fan of that idea in
some sense there's going to be
underlying presuppositions that weight
the manner in which the economic
calculations are made and then of course
you also have to buy the idea that the
cost-benefit analysis approach is
actually valid so can you tell me what
you guys did to forestall such or to
take such criticisms into account
sure
and so first of all uh we don't just ask
one team of economists we also have
other teams critiquing those economists
and we exactly try to make sure that
there's sort of critiques from both
sides if you will so we know that this
is not just an ideologically driven
number but it's actually an empirically
pretty clear number that says for
instance if you focus on on vaccinations
you're actually going to do and what we
find is you're going to do 60 social
good for every dollar you spend
now you could argue well
what would be sort of the ideal
ideological spin you could put on that
well one thing is to say well did you
measure all humans as equal yes we
actually did and of course you could
argue from an economic point at the same
point that they are not i think very few
people would want to do that but what we
do is across all this all these areas
all people are ranked as equally
important that is equally valuable and
that's obviously political consideration
but i think one if we're looking across
the world that is the right one
if anything that probably means that
most rich country people are valued at
way too little compared to what they're
actually willing to do themselves but
this means that we actually get the
waiting right intense sense of saying
where are you going to spend extra money
if your goal is to help the most in the
world right okay so you used an approach
that was basically
i would say a solid measurement approach
uh from from the theoretical perspective
because the idea would be
to have multiple measures of the same
phenomenon or set of phenomena
and and to see where they uh dovetail
so that would be an issue of reliability
so if you have multiple teams of
economists
and they all converge on something that
approximates an agreement and you look
at a diverse range of opinions then you
can be reasonably certain that you've
converged on something that's real and
then you also have an element of peer
review in there
yes another way of ordering
go ahead
and and exactly both of these are
obviously important to make sure as you
say that you get the right reliability
and you actually get something that
resembles somewhat of a truth but the
real point here is of course in some way
if we just take a step back
this is not a question about getting the
absolute numbers exactly right i mean
that would be wonderful if we could do
that uh but when i just told you that
you know vaccination every dollar you
spend will give you sixty dollars back
in the dollar it'd be very very unlikely
that that's the right number but it's
much much more about getting the order
of magnitude right sure you know is it
60 or is it six or is it 600 dollars you
get back because really the point here
is to compare across all these other
things that you could also have spent
that money on and there we have a much
greater
sort of reliability because we're pretty
sure that even if you change the
assumption very much you will still get
much of the same kind of picture you
won't get exactly the same picture but
you'll very much get the same sort of
picture which indicates that there's a
few targets that will do an amazing
amount of good and there's a lot of
targets so just do a little good and so
again we try to say is do the amazing
targets first okay so the more critical
thing for you guys to get right is the
rank ordering and not the absolute
magnitude is long so as long as your
method is
stable across all the different domains
then the rank earning should be
relatively stable now did you get a
pareto distribution with regards to um
positive impact of investment like is
there a handful of interventions that
that are clearly head and shoulders
above the rest in terms of generating
positive economic outcome and
what and what proportion of the total
number of say 170 goals like if you did
if you accomplished 10 percent of the
170 goals how much of the economic bang
for your buck would you would you accrue
i should actually just say i didn't
plant that question that's wonderful
because that's exactly what we tried to
do so if you do across all these areas
every dollar spent will do about seven
dollars good if you just did it across
all of them equally which is probably
unreasonable to assume but it's not you
know unreasonable and sort of first
order uh approximation if you spend it
on the best
19 targets you would do 32 dollars of
good so more than four times more good
so you can simply spend yours the same
dollar and do more than four times more
good than you would do if you just
scatter shot it across all areas and
again what you also have to remember is
a lot of the things that we're looking
at which are really really effective
also things that are much easier to do
so two of the best things that we point
out is actually contraception so family
planning for women why because if you do
that now there's a there's about 13 of
women that still don't have access to
contraception
and if they got that access they would
be able to better space their kids so we
know that that means that you can
actually have your kids when you're
ready to have them that means you put
more effort and investment into your
kids so they'll grow up better they'll
be fed better they'll have a greater
chance of surviving but they'll also
become more productive in the long run
it also means fewer of those kids are
going to die fewer moms are going to die
so we actually estimate you'd see about
600 000 fewer kids die and
you would get a demographic dividend
that is basically because you have
slightly fewer kids you can invest more
in them you get better return on every
kid you have slightly higher growth
rates and so we estimate for every
dollar you spend on family planning you
will do a hundred and twenty dollars of
social good
the other great thing is invest in free
trade uh free trade is something that
we've sort of forgotten uh uh we we
actually had the last
big free trade discussion from doha back
in 1999 it's basically you know stopped
being a concern obviously with trump but
also with many other people who've sort
of given up on free trade yet we have to
remember that one of the basic things
that have made us wealthy is the fact
that we trade with each other you do
what you're good at and i do what i'm
good at and that means when we exchange
we actually all get better off there are
some issues here maybe you could tell
people in some in some detail what what
what that would mean practically like
what are the sorts of barriers that you
guys determined were particularly
troublesome that need to be addressed
so we actually estimated what would it
take to get a reasonably successful dove
around which would not be free trade but
it would be freer trade so it would
simply be reduced tariffs make it easier
for everyone to trade across the world
especially from the developing world to
the developed world and one of the
outcomes we found was not only that on
average every person in the world would
be about a sorry in the developing world
would be about a thousand dollars richer
per person per year in 2030 so by the
end of the sustainable development goals
we would lift 145 million people out of
poverty but we would simply make
everyone better off because
if you're in a poor country you would be
able to sell the things that you do best
a little easier a little cheaper and
hence be able to market more of it and
you'd be able to buy back more from
other developed countries and that would
make everyone better off so again this
is not this is not rocket science i mean
if you look at china for instance uh
china over the last 30 years lifted what
680 million people out of poverty very
largely driven by the fact that they
could trade with the rest of the world
imagine if we could make that happen for
sub-saharan africa if we could make that
happen more for latin america so again
it's more about realizing that for very
little money some of these things can do
an amazing amount of good and we tend to
forget because there's no
focus on these issues we don't think
about uh uh family planning or
or a
free trade or indeed vaccinations we
think about all kinds of other things
like plastic waste or global warming or
many other things that have a lot of
sort of
attention from from celebrities and get
in the newspaper and that's not because
there are no problems but it's about
getting a sense of what's the magnitude
of how much good we can do with little
money okay so let's let's talk about
global warming because by okay so my my
i've talked to lots of people about your
work and you know you obviously have a
lot of admirers and you have a lot of
detractors and i've been listening to
the detractors because
i believed after i had reviewed the un
development goals i'd come to the same
conclusion that you had come to before i
knew what you had done which was these
things need to be recorded because
otherwise it's it's not a plan it's not
a strategy
and so then there has to be some
mechanism for rank ordering them and i
ran across your work and i thought well
that seems to be exactly right i mean
from a from an agnostic perspective
let's say it's an interesting idea
because what you have to start with is
the willingness to be agnostic about
what the worst problems are
and and while the worst and most
solvable problems let's say at the same
time you have to be agnostic about that
and i actually think that that's part of
the reason why what you do bothers so
many people because they have an a
priory commitment to what constitutes
the most salient catastrophe
and that's clearly at the moment is is
that i the idea that
uh climate change um or global warming
depending on how you want to phrase it
um constitutes such an immediate and
pressing threat of of overwhelming
economic magnitude that a sacrifice of
any amount is worth
some probability of forestalling that
and so
um
one of the things that's striking about
your list and maybe what i should do is
have you tell us what the top seven or
eight are just so that we have some
sense of
what the priorities are because one of
the things i noticed was that they don't
tend to include measures that are
designed to forestall global warming
yeah so we actually uh we we had two
nobel laureates uh look over all of
these evidence all of this evidence and
set priorities and come out with 19
targets that they focus on and actually
one of them was uh stop fossil fuel
subsidies which is obviously a stupid
idea in so many different ways uh
remember this is most in developing
countries uh where it's very often done
to
basically pacify the population a little
bit like you make
subsidies for bread or other things
but of course the idea of subsidizing
fossil fuels like venezuela has done and
indonesia has done
is basically a way of subsidizing fairly
wealthy people to drive their car that
you have to have a car in order to enjoy
this uh and drive it more and actually
create more congestion more air
pollution and with very few benefits uh
so clearly what you should be doing is
scrap those subsidies for fossil fuels
not only because they lead to more uh
air pollution and co2 emissions but also
because they're just terribly bad use of
public resources that could have been
spent on education or health or other
places where they could have done a lot
more good but just to give you a sense
of some of the other ones that we were
talking about uh expanded immunization
as we talked about that's a an
incredibly good way we know that we're
right now cut child mortality uh that is
undefined mortality from about 12
million kids dying every year in 1990 to
about 6 million that's a fantastic
achievement but of course 6 million is
still a mind-boggling number that's way
way too large and we actually know that
by investing about a billion dollars we
could save a million kids every year
that you you've got to almost say that
again for a billion dollars you could
save a million kids lives every year why
the hell is that not one of our top
priorities that's also why we show for
every dollar spent you actually do 60
worth of good another incredible uh
investment is in nutrition uh so you
know everybody kind of knows that it's
it's not right that people are starving
and we know that we could actually feed
everyone the main reason why people are
still starving is because they don't
have enough money it's not because we
can't produce it so it's because they're
poor and they don't actually have the
demand capacity but the real tragedy of
of malnutrition is that if you get it
when you're really small so from zero to
two years of age
your brain develops less and that means
when you get into school you're actually
less able to learn and that stays with
you for your entire life you stay less
long in school you learn less and you
come out and you actually are not very
productive we know this now we've had
this as a theoretical argument for a
long time but researchers and some of
the researchers that we work with have
now actually proven this because they
went back to an old study uh done in
guatemala in the late 1960s uh where
researchers went to two small villages
in rural guatemala and gave the kids
there so the really small zero to two
year olds good food and then they took
two other rural villages nearby and gave
the kids essentially sugar water of
course you couldn't do this today but
the brilliant thing about this is our
researchers then we found these kids
they're now in their late 30s early 40s
and you could see what had happened and
it was exactly what the theory predicted
if you had gotten good food you stayed
longer in school you learned more every
year in school and so when you came out
you were much more productive and one of
the ways where you mentioned that is you
had higher incomes if you avoided being
stunted you had 60
higher income that's just a phenomenal
outcome so again spend money for
instance on malnutrition by getting good
food and also research and development
into better yielding varieties and you
can do an incredible amount of good for
every dollar we estimate 35 dollars in
thereabouts
right and so what you're doing is for
stalling cognitive deterioration in the
in the first two years and because
cognitive ability is a great predictor
of long-term success then you're
producing people who are much more
likely to be economically um productive
for themselves and for other people
right and so yeah and the crucial bit is
it's also for other people right if
you're if you're good you're likely to
make other people better too yeah right
oh yes that's an absolutely crucial
issue so
so yeah so so it's quite striking
it was quite striking to me when i came
across your work to find out to what
degree
it was focused on targeting children's
health in some fundamental sense in the
developing world that seems to be
i mean if you had to put it in a
nutshell correct me if i'm wrong that
seemed to be where you guys focused or
where that where your focus took you and
so yeah
what else
can i just say because there's also some
other very low hanging fruit for
instance uh what you're seeing
increasingly across the world is that
more and more people die not of
infectious diseases because we've
actually tackled many of those but they
died from old age diseases like cancer
and heart disease those are by far the
biggest
issues
cancer it turns out to be fairly costly
to deal with but heart disease we've
actually now figured out pretty much how
to deal with not to the extent that we
will live forever but that we can make
people live much longer and that's
basically by giving very cheap and off
patent uh heart medic medication so we
we give this a lot of middle-aged people
in the developed world and it's very
very cheap to also do in the developing
world so we can save about three years
of life for these uh elderly people both
men and women and it cost peanuts and
you can basically make all lives longer
and so that's one of the places where we
also show there's a huge benefit
we also emphasize and this is again one
of the depressing things that we should
be focusing a lot more on tuberculosis
tuberculosis is now the world's leading
infectious disease killer it's no longer
hiv aids that's still a good idea to
invest in but it's actually an even
better idea to invest in tuberculosis
but again because it's an old disease
that's you know it's been with us for
hundreds of years and and we've kind of
learned how to fix it a hundred years
ago it's not an issue in the developed
world so most people don't want to hear
about it don't care about it but it's a
crucial killer that kills 1.4 million
people every year in the developing
world and we have the means to eradicate
pretty much all of those deaths very
very cheaply so again that's one of the
places where we say spend money here
because you can do an amazing amount of
good so i think we're just simply
looking for where are the really good
deals okay if you want to do something
about global warming as you then
you should ask yourself well how are we
going to fix this so there's two things
to global warming one is as you
mentioned there's a sense in which uh
people believe it's the overwhelming
danger that's gonna undermine the
entirety of human civilization and
just like pretty much all other problems
that's just not true this is a problem
it's not the end of the world uh if you
look at the economics that's been done
uh the nobel prize was just awarded in
climate economics to william nordhaus uh
this year uh and he's been a guy working
almost three decades on on on what are
the cost and the benefits of of climate
action and he finds the cost of climate
uh so climate change is about and he's
backed up by a lot of other economists
is somewhere between two and four
percent of gdp by the end of the century
so remember by then we'll be you know
say four or five times richer so we'll
be 405 as rich as we are now but we will
see a drop in our incomes worth about
two to four percent less than we would
otherwise have had that's a problem
but it's by no means the end of the
world and that's the first thing you
sort of need to recognize this is a
problem it's not the end of the world
because if you think you're it's the end
of the world as you rightly point out
then you're willing to throw everything
and the kitchen sink at it but if it's a
problem you will act exactly like what i
think we should do with all problems say
all right there's a lot of problems
let's ask where can we spend a dollar
and fix most of that problem and
unfortunately that's not climate change
it's actually really really hard to just
change a tiny bit of climate change with
a lot of money and that's why we find
that most of the interventions that you
do for climate change turns out to be
fairly poor they're not necessarily bad
investment some of them are uh but even
you know for instance adaptation or or
get more
energy for for poor countries
give you sort of you know two five
dollars back in the dollar which is nice
but in the big scheme of things there
are much much better places you can
spend your resources on so okay so so
let's look at guys look at this well
because i'm really curious about this
hey because
i can't see any
a priory problems with your method it
seems to me to make a lot of sense and
if your goal is to do
the most amount of good in the shortest
period of time with the least amount of
resources which seems like a pretty damn
good goal
then and to be realistic about what's
attainable then i can't see that
anyone's done a better job from a
methodological perspective than you guys
have okay but now but you still face a
tremendous amount of opposition and most
of that does come from the climate side
of things as far as i can tell and so
it's i've been trying to think through
why that might be
and so
when i reviewed the climate literature
which was a few years ago um
i had some real concerns about
measurement accuracy and and so forth
because it's a very complicated issue
and it's not
the
constants that should be associated with
increase in carbon dioxide aren't
obvious and there's quite wide error
bars around them and then carbon dioxide
has all sorts of weirdly complicated
effects like increasing green global
greening which is quite an interesting
one and so
anyways and it also struck me that
the if you project out the climate
change estimates across about a 50 to
100 year period the error bars grow very
large as you move outward obviously
because the errors multiply and then it
struck me that
we're in a situation where the error
bars out 50 years are so wide that even
if we did what people recommended now we
could never be sure that it actually
worked
because you can't the the propagation of
error across all those decades makes the
picture so blurry two or three four
decades down the road that there's no
way of garnering evidence about the
effectiveness of your intervention and
if it's a high cost intervention that
seems to be a really bad idea
so okay so and i'm going to step one
more step backwards which is
so
i also found it difficult to trust the
climate science and the reason for that
was that it struck me as motivated by um
issues
in law
at least in some part that were outside
of the science
it seems to me that a tremendous amount
of what motivates people's psychological
commitment to the idea of climate change
is an underlying something like an
underlying anti-western or
anti-capitalist ethos
and that
the idea is that we should restrict
growth and we should restructure the
economic system and that would address
climate change and that would be a
positive thing and forced all the
apocalypse but the real goal seems to be
more to find an ethical justification
for the political position that requires
the retooling of these economic systems
and so
so
well i guess the first thing i'd like to
know is
what you
does that strike you as a reasonable
argument because i can't see otherwise
why people would be objecting to what it
is that you're doing
yeah so there's there's a lot of
questions in there let me just try to
unpack uh unpack some of this uh
so
we i i think if you look out yes there's
a lot of uncertainty uh going forward um
some of that actually cancels out when
you're saying well we're uncertain about
how much the temperature rise will be
but we do know that if the causal
mechanism is co2 leads to higher warming
if you take some of the co2 out you will
get less of it now we don't exactly know
how much
where you'd get it less whether it was a
lot and up down here a little bit or
whether it was here and down a little
bit but you actually get a little bit
the same thing so you can take some of
the error bars out because you're only
looking at the difference uh and you're
not actually looking at the actual input
uh the the other thing i i i'm in no
doubt that there's a lot of you know
other reasons why people latch on to
social uh phenomena so you know when
when some climate scientists say we
should cut carbon emissions because this
is leading to a really dangerous issue
there's a lot of other people who will
see oh that actually fits with my
ideological uh uh presupposition so i'll
actually join in on uh in this in this
conversation i think that happens in a
lot of different areas uh yeah it is
trying to do is to sort of step back and
say look i'm not going to get into all
of that i'm simply taking as the
starting point we're economists i'm
actually not i'm a political scientist
but all the people i work with are
economists we just take as given what
the climate scientists are telling us
i think it's a it's a it's an
interesting conversation and say
did they actually get it somewhat wrong
um and i think certainly you know
somebody should be looking into it but
but you know i i've met a lot of these
climate scientists my sense is that
they're good hard working you know
scientists are actually trying to find
out what's up and down in this area so
we simply take our starting point with
u1 climate panel what we do is simply
ask
how much will it cost
to cut carbon emissions so much that we
will see a significant change in
temperature and of course remember we
emit co2 not because we want to bother
al gore or anyone else it's a byproduct
of having a life that is incredibly much
nicer than one we would have if we
didn't have access to a lot of energy i
mean we can sit and talk here across the
continent but also you know you have
heating and you're cooling and you've uh
uh fertilizer that subsidize you know
artificial fertilizer that basically
feeds half the world population and a
lot of other benefits that come from
mostly using fossil fuels so if you want
to get rid of some of those fossil fuels
possibly all of them you will have to
replace it with more expensive uh uh
energy and that's why it costs to cut
carbon emissions now that may be worth
the cost but that's exactly the question
that we try to ask and that's what
william nordhaus the nobel laureate in
the uh in climate economics and many
others fast okay so so it's really
important it's really important to note
that you're not questioning the science
as it stands now the consensus so that
this is purely a consequence of economic
calculation this is this is only about
saying good co2 impacts warming and it
does so in the way that the u.n climate
panel tells us now that's not
en entirely true because there's a lot
of things that they tell us and there's
a whole variability and we try to take
that into account but honestly it turns
out that if you do it on the central
estimates you get pretty much what i'm
about to tell you okay so what you find
is if you cut carbon emissions now
you can have a little bit of impact in a
hundred years
but it will have a significant cost now
it's not going to put us to the poor
house nobody's talking about that just
like we're not talking about the end of
the world if we don't do something about
climate change we're not talking about
the end of the world if we do something
about climate change either so i want to
sort of dial back on the rhetoric both
on the alarmists that say oh my god the
world is coming to an end or the people
who are saying oh we can't afford this
and we're all going to the poor house if
you want to you know have solar panels
and wind turbines no
these are both manageable costs these
are sort of in the order you know two to
four percent but the problem is that if
we do sort of things that cost one to
two percent of gdp right now and for the
rest of the century
we basically solve almost no
no part
of the global warming problem we
probably solve about one percent of it
so basically by incurring a cost of one
to two percent of gdp now and every year
throughout the rest of the century
you'll have solved almost none of the
problem come 2100
so you still have to pay all the same
problems that global warming is uh is
incurring
minus a slight amount and then you paid
one to two percent every year that's the
basic idea why most cost benefit
analysis show
that unless you do it very carefully and
only do a little bit of cutting and do
it really smartly
you're actually incurring higher cost
than the problem you're trying to solve
so we can thread the needle and do it
really carefully but that requires a lot
of smartness from a lot of politicians
but if we do it really bluntly we're
just going to incur lots of costs and
actually not get very many benefits okay
so when the people who are not happy
with you for not prioritizing climate
change to the degree that it should be
hypothetically
like how do they criticize your
statements like on what basis do they
decide that your conclusions are
inappropriate
i i think i mean
if if you read most of the internet
there's a lot of things they'll just say
oh you're a denier you can't yeah you
know
we're going to excommunicate you we
don't want to talk to you that's not
right i'm not really going to talk about
those people because that's just that's
political posturing that rather than
anything else i think there's a
reasonable argument to be made to say
that's not the only way that you can
approach this so there's two ways you
can think about cost benefit analysis
actually showing that climate impacts
are worth doing
one is to say ah but there might be a
tiny risk even just a tiny risk that the
whole world is going to spin out of
control and we're all going to die kind
of thing
and you know that's not implausible
especially if you say sort of
i'm not going to put a percentage on it
but it's not it's greater than zero so
there's a non-zero chance that global
warming will spin out of control and
will basically be you know rally get a
few couple a hundred couples of of
humans uh living on an ice-free
antarctic as uh right so that's a
positive feedback loop argument right
that we might trigger mechanisms like
the melting of the greenland ice sheet
for example that would flood the world
or cause some irreparable catastrophe of
unparalleled magnitude okay so i have a
question about that
because that's a tricky one to address
right that's kind of an apocalyptic
argument and then the argument would be
well if there's a one percent chance of
an infinite apocalypse it's worth any
donation of resources to stave it off so
one way of thinking about that is
actually to multiply the catastrophes
because my suspicions are that that same
argument could be used in relationship
to a lot of the other problems that you
are trying to address like
i don't know what the probability is
that if we keep a substantial number of
people in abject poverty over the next
20 years let's say more than we'd have
to
that we would increase the probability
of the generation of um
epidemic and infectious diseases
because poverty
poor people are a risk to everyone in
this hor there's a horrible way of
thinking about it but
poverty is a risk to everyone that's a
better way of thinking about it because
decreased global human health it's also
a breeding ground for all sorts of
catastrophes that might emerge and then
there's also the possibility of
political instability and and nuclear
war and all of those things that are
also equally apocalyptic so
it's it seems to me to be reasonable to
some degree to say look
there's the possibility across a wide
range of potential crises of unforeseen
positive feedback loops spiraling out of
control but we can't introduce them into
the argument unless we can parameterize
them because
all it it's it's an unfair game move in
some sense because you can't be not
wrong about that
exactly and and you're you're basically
saying if if you allow it in in this
area just because you like that
particular area and say i want you to
focus more money on my thing which is
climate change you could equally well do
it in all kinds of other areas and i
actually think you can make your
argument even stronger it's not just not
it's not just that poverty sort of
creates a lot of risk but it's also that
they breed terrorism and willingness to
you know uh do a lot of bad things
you know focused so it's not just
something that happens but you know uh
thrown by terrorism and our ability to
keep you know all the plutonium in the
world under on the lock and and you know
you can get catastrophe from anything
so absolutely abject poverty for example
you could imagine that there might be
two socioeconomic contributions to that
there would be the absolute number of
people in abject poverty who are
therefore desperate and then there would
also be maybe another contribution of
excess
inequality and and the sense that the
world isn't laying itself out fairly and
that that would justify
political political and revolutionary
instability yeah and then also just you
know uh estate failure and many other
things that we know make it a lot easier
for everyone to to make really bad
things like we saw out of uh afghanistan
uh uh uh with 911 a lot of other things
you know once you once you get failed
states you get a lot of bad things
happening right okay so we try to make
people better off we try to make people
better off globally so that we decrease
the probability of of large-scale
political ins political and economic
instability and that's another way of
staving off an apocalypse yes okay and
then
so
can i just so north house actually
looked at this the nobel laureate uh
because some people argued exactly what
you said it's a tiny risk that things go
really really bad so we should spend all
of our money on this issue but of course
that's a failed argument because
likewise there's a lot of small risks
everywhere else we know one risk which
is being hit by an asteroid
that could wipe out the uh the earth yet
and nordhouse did that i thought that
was very very elegant uh uh we know that
we can track all of those asteroids out
there
99.99
but
we chose to only track 90 because
tracking the rest was too expensive so
you can actually see that we put a price
on how much are we willing to do this
and of course that's just one place
where we have a very clear example that
we say
we care somewhat for the future but we
don't care about it entirely we have
lots of other issues that we want to
focus on right now so that's just like
every other area you have to argue
what is the risks and what are the
opportunities to do this and absolutely
given that there are some risks and
they're probably more downside risk and
upside risk for global warming we should
probably do a little more than what we
would otherwise do and that's exactly
what the models show us and those are
the models that we use in making the
estimate of how much should you be
paying for global warming so yes we
should take that into account but it's
not a good argument that was that was
one argument i'm sorry i'll i'll try to
be a little with the other argument the
other argument is that people will say
one of the reasons why it doesn't pay to
do global warming is because you have to
pay now but the benefits come far up
into the future so basically you do
something now that's fairly costly and
then you get a tiny benefit in a hundred
years
so you have to really say the future is
incredibly important in economic speak
that is that the discount is really low
they
really care a lot about the future now a
lot of people would argue we should you
know we're rich we should be able to
care enormously about the future and if
you change that parameter enough and you
say we care enormously about future
generations it actually turns out that
global warming becomes a good deal you
know doing something about global
warming actually becomes goes from you
know saying you spend a dollar and you
do a couple cents of climate damage to
sorry to avoid climate damage you
actually spend a dollar and you might do
two dollars of climate benefit so it
actually turns it into a good idea but
here's the kicker if you care that much
about the future you change every other
one of all of these priorities and make
them boom right because what obviously
happens is you've just said i care so
much about the future that the guy that
i will save from not having tuberculosis
and dying from it tomorrow will now go
on to have a successful life his kids
will live longer they'll do better he
will have a better his you know nation
will do better that means they'll be
much much better off in 2100 and so on
and that means that this is no longer a
question of saying you spend a dollar
and you do 43 dollars worth of good but
you spend it all in you a thousand
dollars worth of good so what you've
achieved is basically just made
everything a great idea and that's also
intellectually making the discount rate
very very small what it means is you
should basically starve you should just
eat porridge every day and spend all of
the rest of your money on the future
because you care so much about it right
now if you do that i i applaud your sort
of your your consistency but most people
just don't do this and we certainly
don't do this in the way that you know
we don't seem to care all that much
about our pension systems which are in
many rich countries going to fail in the
next 20 to 40 years yeah and all these
other issues so as long as you're saying
no no what you're really saying then is
on climate we want to care a lot about
the future but we don't want to do it in
all other areas okay
you need to do it across all areas and
then you need to be very hungry and only
forage right okay so your claim
basically from a methodological
perspective is that your rank ordering
remains constant across variable
discount rates
yes right and that's a really that's a
really important that's a really
fundamentally important it's not entire
i i gotta say it does change some of
these yeah sure
because obviously you know education for
instance is one of those where you pay
now and you only get benefits 10 20 you
know 50 years out when the kids grow up
and actually become much more productive
so there is a change but mostly the
rancor ordering remains the same and i'm
simply just insisting that people need
to be consistent you can't just say uh
the future is important when you talk
about climate yeah you want to say the
future is important it's important
across all areas and then you really
have to do everything and you know
forego uh having a good life yourself
right right
okay well so the other thing that's
worthwhile pointing out about the
discount rate is that you know you can
make a case that the future is more
important than the present especially
because it extends out so far but but
the other reason that people discount
the future is because you can't make the
case that you can predict the outcome of
your actions
and that means that the error in
prediction magnifies itself as you move
out further in time frame and so what
happens is you get to a point where
there isn't a lot of point in adjusting
your behavior in the present if you look
like a hundred years out let's say or a
thousand years old because you actually
can't calculate with any accuracy the
consequence of your actions or inactions
and so the the cumulative error makes
discounting the future the appropriate
thing to do because you can predict
what's going to happen if you act now
now and maybe tomorrow but you get much
less accurate as as you move forward so
even if in the best case scenario where
we had the best wishes for the future
that doesn't mean we could justify
incredibly radical sacrifices now
because we can't calculate their
cumulative impact
now
there's a good there's a good way of
thinking about this you know if you look
at what previous generations have done
for us the only thing that they've
really managed to do is to give us a lot
more knowledge so investment in
knowledge is actually a great way to
help future generations because it
helped them in all kinds of ways and we
can't really predict how but it's
probably a good idea to leave them with
a lot of you know books i'm i'm using as
a as a metaphor but trying to help them
in a specific way imagine back a hundred
years ago yeah our forefathers back in
the 1920s uh no
1910s uh would have would have done
reasonably to help us now chances are
they would have wasted a lot of money on
things that never turned into problems
there's a wonderful book called today
now uh uh sorry
oh god i'm forgetting uh tomorrow now
oh god what uh
anyway it is
it has a great and clever title which
i've clearly screwed up now uh but it
was uh back in 1893 uh the uh the world
fair in chicago i believe asked 50 of
the world's smartest people to predict
what would the world look like in a
hundred years
and so all of them first star said you
know i love the fact that i'm not going
to be around when this prediction comes
you know true or not uh but then they
made all their predictions and they were
almost entirely off yeah there's some
pretty close uh you know there's not one
that predicted sort of email in the
sense of you know those
i can't pronounce that pneumatic
pneumatic tubes yep which is sent away
and you know it would sort of
suck it out and so you could send a
letter somewhere they imagined that that
would be a worldwide thing and so you
could actually send a letter everywhere
you just sort of put it in the very very
long tube right right which is kind of
right
and you can sort of see yeah yeah that's
not entirely wrong you know got the
whole technology wrong but the right
idea
but the fundamental point is we're
probably wrong about so many things as
you say that trying to help the world in
the future by for instance cutting
temperature might be one of the least
effective ways of helping also so
there's another thing that that's
interesting about that i think that
speaks to the
fundamental intelligence of your
approach so
one of the things that has struck me as
highly likely is that given how complex
things are and how rapidly they're
changing
that the best thing we could do to
prepare ourselves for the future would
be to make better people
smarter people wiser people more
responsible people all of that so that
there's a psychological element to that
and so
i would say some of my work has
concentrated on that and the public
lectures that i've been doing but what's
interesting about your approach the
economic approach is that you're
diverting a lot of resources to the
creation of better people for tomorrow
by investing especially in in childhood
nutrition so if you and i suppose this
is kind of how economists look at the
world but maybe biologists could look at
it this way too
if you think of people as general
problem-solving machines which is not a
bad way of thinking about us then it
might be that given that you don't know
which problems are going to be paramount
what you want to do is improve the
machines that will solve the problems
whatever those problems happen to be and
so that investment in early childhood
um development seems particularly
apropos in that regard and
so having said that i want to return to
the climate issue one more time because
here's something peculiar this is
something i don't understand
it's a real mystery so let's say that
just for the sake of argument that most
of the people who are concerned about
climate change and its relationship to
economic development are on the left
side of the spectrum
okay but let's also say that those who
are on the left side of the spectrum are
hypothetically also concerned with the
economic well-being of the most
dispossessed
and that those might be equally
important concerns and they're
integrally logged together well the
strange thing about so many of your
recommendations is that they're directly
aimed at addressing the immediate now
concerns of the fundamentally
dispossessed and so you'd think that
that that's part of the reason that i
can't understand why there's so much
objection to your methods because it's
not like
what you came up with looks like support
for something that's like a right-wing
agenda by any stretch of the imagination
first of all it's predicated on the idea
that there's a certain amount of
development aid especially directed to
children you said not exclusively there
would be of great use and it seems to me
to be undeniable that the most
dispossessed people in the world are
impoverished infants of impoverished
people
so
what if some of the objections to what
you're doing are ideologically motivated
why doesn't that cancel it out it's a
good question i i don't quite understand
it my sense is that in some ways so so i
was in new york in september uh there
was a uh uh the first ever uh summit at
the un uh for tuberculosis and i was
there because one of the things that
we've identified is this is a great
investment and of course all the
tuberculosis people love us because you
know we're pointing out you should spend
more money on their problem um and and
unfortunately almost nobody went
i wrote an abba together with the south
african health minister and it was
widely published in the developing world
but almost no one in the developed world
picked it up it was only when i wrote
another op-ed where i said there were
two meetings taking place in new york
one was this tv place where you know
biggest infectious disease killer in the
world where almost nobody turned up and
then there was the other meeting uh
which macron and uh the french president
and uh bloomberg and others attended to
which was the climate summit which
everybody attended to yeah yeah you know
i sort of pointed out the the
disparity and then it was picked up in
all kinds of developed country papers i
think fundamentally it goes down to
saying while everybody says they care a
lot about the world's poor the reality
is that
you care somewhat for it but
most rich well-meaning people probably
care a lot more about the fact that they
worry that their kids might be in a
position where global warming is really
going to undermine but even that even
that doesn't make sense because look we
already established the fact that
there's equal reason to be
apocalyptically concerned about
unchecked poverty and inequality
so this is why i i suggested to begin
with that
the one of the lovely things about the
idea of climate change is that it it
really justifies the idea of
overthrowing the current system or of
undermining the current system and that
if you're inclined to do that rather
than inclined to truly help the
dispossessed let's say then you'd be
more inclined to support a theory that
justifies that sort of radical let's say
interventionist policy and i can't see a
way out of that logically given that
the the work that you're doing on
tuberculosis is a great example is
directly and
evidentially associated with a marked
increase in the well-being of the
dispossessed and so you'd think that
you think that would attract the proper
amount of ideological attention but it
doesn't and that's that's a great
mystery there's something about that
extraordinarily and and it's it's a good
point and and i i think you have a a
consistent argument the the thing that
i've i've decided a long time ago that i
don't want to argue and and i think
that's probably the difference between
being more psychologically focused i
don't want to argue on what i think
might be people's uh sort of inner
motivations i want to actually take them
at face value and you know many people i
meet they say i worry a lot about
climate change i worry a lot about the
world's poor and then i try to show them
well if you actually do that why the
hell would you be focusing on spending
lots of money they'll almost do no good
instead of spending possibly less money
and doing it hopefully about yeah more
good and it creates some cognitive
dissonance and i think it switches
people a little bit towards spending
smarter but yes you're right but tell
them also it also might just be
ignorance you know it's like what you're
doing is pretty new
and it takes a long time i mean it's not
new for you and it's not new
considering the span of a single
lifetime but you know what you're doing
is very radical in some sense there and
there isn't anybody else doing it and so
it might only it might be that it will
take 20 years or 25 years or something
like that for the approach that you're
uh um
publicizing and have developed to for
people to actually know about it
you know and so what what do they say
you should assume ignorance instead of
malevolence when you can
i do think that ignorance is a part of
this it's not obvious to everyone that
there is this method of rank ordering
that people have done it and and that
there are consequences to that that
could be laid out in an intelligent
economic plan you know and i know that
it takes a finding in the scientific
literature if it's going to make its way
into the public something approximating
15 years
and and and that's only the ones that
actually do manage to make it and so it
could be that
just way more people need to know what
you're doing and why and how it was done
before it gets the steam going i'm
interested in the psychological issues
in part to try to help figure out
what it would take to motivate people to
be more attentive to the sorts of
solutions that you and your people have
been putting forward and to eliminate
those barriers but but uh but it could
just be as i said it could just be
ignorance and and
one of the one of the problems that
we're facing constantly and i know why
there's no one else doing this and we
that we're doing because
when you do prioritization and you
inevitably end up antagonizing a lot of
people i mean uh climate change is the
most obvious one but for instance uh
sanitation water and sanitation huge
problem uh so you know there's about two
and a half billion people affected by
this one of the points that we emphasize
is that doing sanitation while a good
thing to do it probably only pays you
back three dollars back in the dollar
why because it's actually fairly costly
to do sanitation and also because the
benefit's not nearly as great as what
many have assumed and this is the new
global burden of decisions estimates
that the real problem is
that what you're doing with sanitation
is that you're not removing fecal matter
from the environment you're simply
reducing the amount so you're not
actually having all that much of an
impact on decease you're having a little
bit but not nearly as much as what we
would like to see that obviously pisses
off all the people who are doing
sanitation and you know we end up
pissing off a lot of people and the the
truth is i think it's necessary if
you're going to do this that when you
rank order of course the the the cost is
to come out on top love it and the
causes that don't don't love it but it's
also important to make that argument and
so so at the end of the day certainly my
sense is it's necessary to do it but it
will always
entail a great amount of sort of
unease uh because it doesn't feel like
we're saying you know kumbaya and we
should do everything but we're actually
saying no you should do these things but
not all of these things although they
seem nice they're just not in the same
league
right right right right well
that that's
it would be nice if we could do
everything good that we possibly could
all at once
but it's not
it's not realistic because you can't do
everything at once and you don't have
infinite resources as we've already
pointed out so okay so what would you
say
would be
if you're going to play devil's advocate
against your own position which i
presume you've done a lot of anyways
what are their criticisms against your
let's say your your aims and your
methods
that you regard as
unresolved like what is it that you're
doing that's still weak and wrong in
your own estimation or where the where
the limitations in your methods well
look there's
no method does everything so we have two
very obvious problems one is not all
issues is about money
so we're looking at how do you
prioritize money but sometimes money is
not the issue for instance on free trade
as we talked about before we estimate
the benefit is incredible but we
actually look at the cost as the cost of
subsidizing western farmers because
those are the ones that basically uh
make a you know killing from not freeing
up uh global markets and those are the
ones that usually uh kept uh held it
back but what has happened is it has
become much more sort of an emotional
thing it's sort of an identity thing and
i'm not sure how we you would cost that
so to the extent
that things have not nothing to do with
money but they're just simply about
political willingness or interest or uh
uh want uh then we are not making the
argument uh that is going to convince
you so in some sense we are telling you
where can you spend money but we're not
talking about the things that don't
require money right so people would
object that you're that the problem with
your method is that
you're measuring everything that can be
tangibly measured from an economic
perspective but that's actually a small
fraction of the universe of properly
attended to
i think i would tend to say it's
probably you know sort of 70 or 80 i'm
not quite sure how you make that up but
but you know yeah the biggest the
biggest policy decisions in most
countries is the national budget uh it's
very clear that that is a very
substantial part of what we decide how
are we going to allocate money well the
problem really is a big issue
right well the problem with the
objection is that well the people who
are objecting could be right that your
methods are narrow i mean you're making
the case you're not as narrow as a yeah
as a pessimist might assume but that
puts the onus on them to come up with an
alternative way of ranking
right i mean i would just say we're not
talking about those last 30 that are you
know purely about uh you know should we
have transgender bathrooms or something
yeah well that's possibly a bad idea
because that actually has cost and
building a third
bathroom or something but you know there
are some things that are mostly just
about uh what do you think what do you
believe what what are your intuitions uh
rather than actual costs right but
there's no way of adjudicating between
those claims that's the problem that all
that people do is push each other around
about them if they can't yeah
there's still a substantial amount of
issues where you do need to look at
resource allocation and there we have a
good argument the second part the second
sort of criticism uh which is a very
fair criticism is we don't look at
inequality
so economists are very very bad at
dealing with inequality because
fundamentally that's a political issue
so when we look at you spend a dollar
and you do sixty dollars worth of good
we don't look at who gets that sixty
dollars now
to be fair most of the things as yours
all you've also pointed out most of the
things that we actually indicate are
really really low-hanging fruit in the
world are things that will help the
world's poorest mostly because the
world's poorest have so many things that
they haven't gotten that would be hugely
beneficial for them so it mostly
actually helped also inequality but we
don't measure it and so we don't
actually look at would this be a good
expenditure in the
in the sense of helping the world's
poorest mostly would but it's not part
of our framework and there's
making that well because uh because cost
benefit analysis is basically assuming
that everybody is equally worth the wait
we talked about that that earlier
there's there's no way of of sort of
well you can but it becomes incredibly
unclear and and very unintuitive if you
start making waitings and on who is
actually worth more
so so we are we're again saying it's a
little bit like the menu you know you
get in the restaurant we're telling you
hey the spinach is cheap and it has lots
of vitamins and the cake is expensive
and it's bad for you but you know you go
ahead and make the choice
and i think that's the fair way to have
that conversation that we're telling you
some important facts about your
decisions but these are not the only
things that are going to guide your
decision and i'm absolutely happy to say
that so so in some sense you asked me to
be you know devil's advocate i i just
think it's important to clarify we don't
look at all issues because we only look
at issues that require resources and we
don't deal with inequality which is also
an important issue but apart from that
we have to make priorities and we're
simply making a little clearer at the
end of the day you can choose to totally
disregard it but i would imagine that
you would at least like to know
what does the evidence tell you if you
spend a dollar here how many people will
you save how many lives will be improved
how much environment will be improved
and so on versus all the other things
where you could have spent that dollar
and done different amounts of good in
all those different areas
and that's what we provide for the menu
so do you okay okay well i appreciate
that very much um do you have any sense
what
do you off the top of your head
what the total capital expenditure for
the minimization or eradication of
tuberculosis actually would be what are
you talking about in absolute dollar
amounts
so it and and and it depends a lot on uh
because uh so we estimated you need
about two billion dollars the uh the uh
the global funds that we were also
campaigning with uh are saying it's
about 5.8 billion dollars and to be
quite honest i'm not quite sure which of
these two numbers is the right number i
i think the uh but you know
compared to you know just to give you a
sense of proportion uh the the amount of
subsidies that we give to solar and wind
uh is about
120 billion dollars right now uh so you
know we're talking about a very very
small amount uh and certainly it's a
very small amount and you know it's it's
about what um
three four percent of global development
uh spending so the amount of spending
that we that we spend every year to try
and help improve the world and it will
probably be one of the very very best
things that we could do so again very
very simple people
would start to care if they actually
knew so okay i got two
final questions for you i think and then
i'll ask you if there's anything else
you wanted to that bring to people's
attention that that you thought was
particularly necessary okay so the first
one is um
to what degree do you think i'll ask all
three questions to what degree do you
think you've been making headway like
obviously you've been successful in
putting together your institutes and and
your work has garnered a substantial
amount of attention published and
otherwise and so it's not like you've
been silenced and and and imprisoned or
anything like that and so
are there reasons for optimism as far as
you're concerned and
and then the next thing that i'd like to
ask you about is what's happening in
france
because
one of the things that the people who
are pushing
for radical current interventions with
regards to long-term climate change
haven't factored in is the reverse
apocalyptic issue which is that there's
going to be substantial resistance to
the short-term costs that will cause
spin-off disasters of their own and so
the french example seems to be a very
interesting case and point so
so the first question was
how do you feel about the impact that
you're having and the second is what do
you have to say about what's happening
in france yeah can can i i'm gonna
answer them in reverse because i think
the the france point is is really a good
a a good argument if you ask people
around the world uh do you care about
global warming almost everyone will say
yes uh do you want to do something for
global warming they'll say yes then when
you ask them how much are you willing to
pay the typical answer
both in rich and poor countries is a
couple hundred dollars per year so yeah
goes from 100 to 200
so fundamentally what people are saying
is yes i do worry about this issue i'm
willing to spend a little bit of money
but not very much and i think this is
the fundamental thing that we just have
not been able to get to the attention of
a lot of people who are pushing for
really really radical solutions you're
never going to succeed in a democratic
situation uh if you know if you keep
ramping up uh the taxes on on fossil
fuels if you keep making uh energy more
and more expensive it's going to harm
first of all the poor the most yes
very very regressive and that obviously
is
means a lot of heartache for a lot of
poor people these are typically also the
people who are least able to defend
themselves because they're just so busy
uh just surviving of their day-to-day so
it typically has to hit the middle class
before you really get sort of an
eruption as what you've seen in france
and elsewhere let's remember there's
also a lot of other issues in france so
it's not just because they put you know
three three sets on on on on a liter of
diesel but it is an issue of saying if
you push people too far you will
actually not be able to do the solution
for climate and so your very very
expensive solutions are never going to
be long-term viable you know when you
predict these ideas of saying if we had
obama
and if he would actually have managed to
put a carbon tax on on on co2 remember
he actually had a democratic congress uh
the first two years of his uh presidency
and they were still not able to get a
carbon tax implemented but of course
when you have a republican uh congress
it becomes really hard when you have a
republican president also it falls apart
you just can't do this for a hundred
years it's just not going to work out
and that's why uh and and we never got
to that we actually did a a a climate
consensus where we brought together 27
of the world's top climate economists
three nobel laureates to look at where
can you do good for climate and what
they found was the by far best
investment to tackle global warming is
to invest in green energy r d
so fundamentally if we could invest in
making better green energy for the
future
hopefully eventually get it to be so
cheap that it will out compete fossil
fuels we will solve global warming just
simply because the green energy became
cheaper if you'll allow me a slight
detour back in the 1860s uh the world
was hunting whales to extinction because
whales have this wonderful
should i just say that again yep
yeah all right
back in the 1860s we were hunting whales
to extinction because whales have this
wonderful oil that just burns a lot
cleaner and a lot more bright and so it
was wonderful for the houses in in in
north america and europe to burn these
uh this whale oil and they were all
excited about it and it had the
bad side effect that was actually uh
pushing whales to extinction now the
sort of global warming approach to that
problem would have been to say could you
please turn down the light could you
please have it a little less light in
your room and of course you would have
entirely failed what did save the whales
was
we discovered oil you know fossil fuel
oil which were actually burning cleaner
it was much cheaper and you didn't have
to go out and kill whales for it and so
what happened about a decade was you
stop killing whales because you got a
better technological product and we've
seen this a lot of times that technology
can simply invalidate an old issue a
problem that you thought was almost
intractable if you get cheaper smarter
new technology people will switch right
that's proposing imposing limits
expensive limits on people is not an exp
appropriate long-term solution because
of implementation resistance and cost
and the best solution is to come up with
a well let's say to put it in a cliched
manner is to come up with a better
solution
which is cheaper energy that's that that
has all the advantages and fewer
disadvantages and that's really how the
problem wind turbines solar panels and
and now i'm just taking the two most
popular things and batteries together if
they were cheaper than fossil fuels
which they aren't right now but if they
were of course everyone would buy them
we'd stop buying coal-fired power plants
so it's really not rocket science in
that way now i'm not saying it's going
to be easy and it's certainly not going
to happen right now but it's the only
viable long-term solution it's much
cheaper and much more effective so we
estimate it that for every dollar spent
you'll actually do about 11 of climate
benefit okay so that's one that's not
that's on alternative energy
yes yes okay
so
by far yeah so so it's it's not the best
thing but it comes down here so it
actually you know it's a pretty good
investment yeah it's not the best in the
world but we should definitely be doing
it okay the second question that you had
was the you know the optimism so you
know fundamentally how much of
an impact does this have well it's had
the impact and very predictable impact
that when we come out and say for
instance uh in uh uh more immunization
gives you sixty dollars back on the
dollar the people who are doing
immunization
tells you all the time you should fund
us because we do sixty dollars and good
for every dollar you spend so very
clearly uh yeah i sat down with a guy
from uh from uh uh uh a family
foundation a big family foundation and
you know we were at a malaria event and
and you know he we sat and politely
conversed and he uh uh yeah he would say
so what do you do i well i work with the
copenhagen consensus center he you know
totally blacks there uh and then i asked
him what would you do uh well we work
with malaria you know did you know that
actually if you spend a dollar in
malaria you'll do 33 dollars worth of
good and i was like yeah we did that
number and you know and and yeah this is
exactly the point we're not we're not
there to you know get attention we're
there to make sure that we get attention
to some of these top ideas and i think
we've definitely helped a lot of these
top ideas get a little easier ride in
the world okay so let me ask you another
cost benefit okay so yes so
what if i said
wouldn't it be interested
interesting in doing a meta cost benefit
analysis on how much money you would
need to raise and spend to effectively
market your findings you know and to
hire people who are really good at doing
such marketing so that you had the
appropriate advertisements and so that
you because you're you're this is not a
criticism believe me but your approach
is very academic and very objective and
and that's all well and good and
reliable and valid and all of those
things but
do you do you could your economists
compute the utility in dollar value of
establishing an ex an extensive and
appropriate marketing scheme because
you'd think that there are actually
because i've been watching what's been
happening with the democrats in the u.s
and they've uh a pack that that i know
about has been
uh
making new ads for the democrats
trying to move them to towards the
center and they've had a substantial
amount of impact because the
advertisements have been very
professionally crafted and constructed
and so
well i don't i don't know what you think
about that but i've been
part of the reason i'm interviewing you
today is because i want to put this up
on youtube and i want to get it out
there and podcast so that more people
know about this
and so
all right
yeah so so the short answer of course is
we have tried to do that because we're
economists and we think that would that
would be a good idea so let me just tell
you about something else that we've done
so uh so we've been working a lot and we
were just talking about the globe uh so
when you do prioritization on the
planetary scale it's academically very
interesting but unfortunately the impact
is mostly that people say yeah that's
probably true somewhere else you know so
when we go and tell the indians this
they'll say yeah that's probably true
for mexico and mexico will say it's
probably true for argentina and so so
everybody just pushes it off to somebody
else
the world is never anyone's problem yeah
someone else needs to fix this and so
what we've increasingly done is to do
this in nations
uh so we did this a couple years ago in
bangladesh uh and in the nation of
course there's an overlap between who
actually decides where to spend the
money and the problems that we're
analyzing so we did the exact same thing
for just for bangladesh so we did a
prioritization list of all the things so
we talked to everyone in bangladesh we
got them to say what are the best things
that you want to focus on what are the
smartest news solutions we work with
prime minister think tank the finance
minister everybody else and talk about
where can you actually spend money right
again this is this is a menu that's not
entirely politically correct certainly
the politicians don't like all of this
but what they you know the finance
minister would go like no no no oh yes
yes i like this yeah and so they did
some of the things so that solves the
tower of babel problem to some degree is
that in too much
yeah there's too much distance between
the local and the global and so yes
you're using the nation state as a as a
psychological
intermediary
yeah so there we actually estimate that
every dollar spent on what we were doing
uh does you know at least ten thousand
dollars worth of good simply because we
helped shift spending in bangladesh both
on their national budget but also the
development budgets spending in
bangladesh and again we didn't change
you know bangladesh to suddenly become
super rational or anything yeah we
simply changed it a little bit we gave
if you will headwind to the poor ideas
and tailwind to the good ones and so we
call that in haiti we're we're now doing
this in india together with tata trust i
just came back so that's why i'm a
little jet lag or a little bleary-eyed i
just came back uh from from ghana uh
where we're going to do our next project
so we want to bring this to africa
great you can do it globally and locally
yes and i think we'll have a lot more
opportunity to actually get people's
attention when you talk specifically to
the nation states where you're actually
going to be making these decisions but
obviously if it's true in ghana it's
probably also true in the neighboring
state you're going to get the
exactly so i think i would love to you
know uh have have uh i have have a lot
of uh extra sort of pr ability but i
think what we what we really need is
just simply to be able to come up with
all these great ideas and i think we are
reasonably successful but but the
problem in some ways is we're advocates
of all the boring stuff you know all the
stuff that gets the attention are the
ones that have the crying babies and
cute animals the thing is it's not true
it's not what you're doing isn't boring
it's absolutely exciting beyond belief i
mean i i don't believe that it is dry
and i don't believe that it doesn't have
a powerful narrative message it's just
that there are reasons that the
narrative message is obscured and i
think putting your finger on the gap
between the local and the global is a
good one that's smart because
you you see the same problem starting to
emerge for example with the eu where the
overarching bureaucracy is so distant
from the people on the ground that
there's a disconnect in identification
and so to harness the latent power of
the nation state and its patriotism and
its at its economic what would its
rather local economic structure seems to
me to be a really smart solution but i i
really i was thrilled when i came across
your work
and i mean on an emotional level because
i thought well wow if we really wanted
to do good if that was the goal and we
wanted to do it intelligently and
carefully and and agnostically to some
degree um and in a non-ideologically
self-serving manner which would be a
lovely thing to manage if it was
possible then this seemed to be an
incredibly exciting approach and i
i believe that there's every reason to
assume that with proper publicity
that people could really get behind the
idea that we wouldn't have to have
tuberculosis in 10 years
you know and that some of these things
could really and you know i've talked to
people in on my lecture tour about the
things that we could do to make the
world a better place and there's no
shortage of enthusiasm for that it's
just that there's a fair bit of cynicism
but there's a lot more ignorance is like
well we just don't know what to do but
your prescriptions say well
here's 10 things you could do one of
them and one of them would work
so you've got a bit of a choice there we
wouldn't have to take our number one
priority as your own but you could take
number five and you'd still do a lovely
job and it might be in accordance with
your own motivations
okay
can it can can you
get me
pdfs for example of the relevant
whatever you think is relevant that
would inform people in short order i
will post in the description of the
video
so that people can get access to that so
whatever material you'd like to have
disseminated as a consequence of this
conversation just get that to me and
i'll post it and any blurb you want me
to put in the description then i'll also
do that with with whatever
when do you need it for but as soon as
soon as you can get it because i'll put
this up
very soon like in the next video yes all
right
is there anything else that you would
like to say that we haven't covered
i mean first of all i i think it's
wonderful the way that you're you're
talking about this uh as sort of an
outsider that it's actually exciting uh
because we we and we probably make this
mistake that we think of ourselves a
little bit sort of technocrats and and
you know fiddlers in the march and uh
kind of thing and it actually you're
right and it is exciting because it is
ridiculously exciting actually if we
could actually spend our resources four
times as well as what we're doing right
now so instead of saying all the things
that are politically correct making us
all feel warm and fussy actually doing
the things that perhaps are not top of
our mind not top of the uh
the agenda but would just do an amazing
amount of good why the hell are we not
doing that so yeah so
thank you very much for for getting me
back in the groove and actually so i
really i really believe that and
incredibly uh useful yeah yeah so
i think i think it's a mistake not to
view what you're doing as a as an
exciting adventure i think it's a form
of of what uh it's a form of non-helpful
humility
yeah
and i think yeah and and i think we i
i'm danish uh uh uh background and and
one of the things we're very very good
at is self defacement uh and so yes
you're probably right so you're calling
people
you're calling people to a great
adventure here yes you're saying look we
have enough resources so that we could
deflect a small fraction of them
and do an unbelievable amount of good
and and there would be no downside to
that
there would be no downside to anyone
there would be nothing but upside even
with some error and there's going to be
error and so of course there's no i
think we'll find that people will
respond to this video in a very very
positive way and because they're i i do
believe that there
as people become more aware that we are
becoming richer and that we do have more
resources at our disposal that that's
genuinely true and that with a bit of
intelligent consideration we could make
things a lot more less dismal for a lot
of people i think that they will start
to view that as something that's part of
a great globe national and global
adventure and and because you're
agnostic and because you've done the leg
work
then people can also i think get behind
that without any real cynicism they can
say look
our money spent here is not going to be
wasted we can be reasonably assured that
if we're charitable in this direction
we're going to do something positive and
so so anyways like i said i found it
incredibly
wonderful and let me let me just say uh
again we said a couple of times
something that i've done i i i need to
say you know i'm i'm just the puppet
that talks about all these things the
this is the work of an incredible amount
of really really smart economists so
more than three of the world's top
economists you know seven nobel
laureates those are the guys who've
actually done the work and who are you
know giving the credibility uh to all of
this uh this research and that's why we
can say with great amount of certainty
this is not just sort of a a whim but
something that is probably the best we
know now it's probably as you point out
not entirely true but it's certainly
better than anything else we have right
now right so
that's it well and that's actually the
right comparison it's like it's not
absolutely true yeah but no one's got a
better idea
right so we go with the best idea that
we have
exactly right right all right well look
it was a great pleasure talking to you
and uh i'm hoping that you know a
million people will watch this and that
will get another million podcasts out of
it and that this will help disseminate
what you're doing broadly i think that
would be i think that would be lovely
you bet thank you good thank you
and you know it was it was great also
meeting you and i hope our paths will
cross again soon and uh you know we
should we should make a habit of this
yes we definitely should well when you
start to develop some more of the
national indices have you worked on any
western countries like canada or the
united states or so we we i wanted to do
that so we we haven't done it in the us
just simply because it's too
dysfunctional in so many different ways
we've seen a couple of other people
trying to do this without our
involvement and one of the things we're
really really good at is that you know
you get all these economists to do all
this stuff and the first draft of the
paper is this is really hard we need 10
years a lot of research money and then
we'll probably get you something and you
know we say look that's that's nowhere
you gotta you know give it your best
shot get use the information that's out
there now and give us a knowledge
because politicians are going to make
decisions next year uh and and what has
happened in those two places so they did
one in holland they did
it might actually be canada but that was
like 10 years ago uh it ends up very
much like a very interesting anthology
of of of points that yes yes directions
i have no sort of consistency is what
we're trying to
achieve what would it cost to have what
would it cost to have something like
this done for canada
uh
the short version is it cost about two
and a half million dollars simply it's
it's it doesn't really scale well uh so
you know doing it for for ghana is the
same thing as doing it for canada how
long would it take
uh 18 months
god that's such a good idea so two and a
half million dollars 18 months
yeah
okay well i'm going to wrap that around
maybe we can figure out how to raise the
money we should we should try and do
that that would be good
i think there would be a lot of interest
in canada and canada would be a great
way to also get sort of bridge point
into the us without doing it in the us
yeah yeah well that that would be good
because we're flailing about politically
and it would be nice to yes okay so so
that's that's that's that's that's
fodder for another conversation we i've
got a couple of other conversations that
i'd like to have with you about policy
development and also about marketing but
we'll save those for another time
brilliant
join it was great talking to you again
thank you very good we'll send you this
stuff uh so basically tonight that's
great wonderful wonderful yeah i'll get
this up as soon as i can
wonderful all right talk to you soon
okay take care bye bye